welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video we're
breaking down Black Mirror B on the sea
[Music]
the entry takes a really dark turnout
point and throughout this video we're
going to be going through that final
scene all the things that led up to it
and every connection we could find to
the other Black Mirror episodes now the
song beyond the sea is used throughout
the entry and this carries a hell of a
lot with it it's a tune that's pretty
much enter the pop cultures like I saw
the last couple of years with it being
used in a lot of films and TV shows the
most recent one I can think of is a
quiet place too which is where it was
used to Signal Sanctuary on an island
Beyond the Sea by there here it's usage
is a lot more metaphorical with its
lyrics being what state we find the
characters in the lyrics center around a
couple separated by the sea with the
singer longingly talking about how one
day they'll be together that's what
happens in this episode too with both
our quote-unquote Sailors out in space
and having to share a body to be with
the person that they love this depiction
set in 1969 and it's an alternate
universe in which space travel has some
upsides to it whilst people are out on
their Journeys they're capable of
traveling back to Earth through neural
link and inhabiting machines now known
as replicas so that they can be with
their family now one thing about space
travel is that it would definitely be
lonely and this allows them to have a
link back on Earth that they can be with
for their own sanity I'm guessing
Brucker came up with the idea during
lockdown and as we know several people
were forced to remain inside which could
be torturous if they were by themselves
I'd imagine it would be like solitary
confinement so the link back home is
extremely important however the episode
questions what would happen if that link
was severed and those in space had to
remain there whilst dealing with the
pain that they'd lost everything back
home there'd be no way to Return to the
Planet unless they'd be stuck wondering
what was happening with no way to
contact anyone now the two men we follow
are David and Cliff who are out in space
in their Voyage both are opposites to
each other with David finger banging his
wife and having intimate moments of
romance whereas Cliff refuses to touch
it things take a turn for the worst when
a murderous cult shows up at David's
house and they brutally kill his family
in front of him and then destroy his
replica I was wondering why they didn't
reverse things and send the replica into
space face but I'm guessing that they
did it the other way around so they
could fix things on earth if it came to
it you also wouldn't have an episode if
that was the case and yeah but it was
just something I thought about when
watching it yeah my mind my mind starts
to wonder now David's of course hit with
agonizing pain and Cliff and his wife
blonde decide to offer a kindness to him
and allow him to use Cliff's replica it
basically becomes Cooks in space with
David overstepping boundaries the more
and more he visits initially he's
thankful to just get a hug but before
too long he's traveling into town
hitting their son and making moves on
Lana he plays Beyond the scene in order
to try and seduce her which is something
that he also did with his deceased wife
sharing Cliff's body he gives Lana what
she's been craving and somewhat
weaponized is the love that he and his
wife used to have the two are very much
Beyond the Sea and this is because
they're separated by the metaphorical
distance between them which is keeping
them apart he sees Cliff as someone who
doesn't appreciate what he has and
having lost it all he thinks he'd give
Lana what she desires his artistic seems
kind and comforting and even from the
intro we see him sketching his two kids
how about with Lana he oversteps the
line and basically makes the 60s version
of Deep fake Newt guy can't let Cliff
have what he wants either and in the end
he kills Lana and their son stranding
them both in space offering him a chair
come the final shot he's very much
welcoming him to come and join him in
hell now Cliff only has two choices here
and he can either sit beside him and
have some company or he can kill David
and suffer the agonizing Adventure
without him though I think this episode
went on way way too long the final
moment is something I think I'm gonna
remember for a long time as it made me
question what I do in this exact same
situation now personally might be
something you disagree with but
personally I don't think that Cliff
would have took the deal this was a man
who was already used to the distance now
we know that he wasn't intimate with his
wife or close to his son at all
therefore he could potentially be
mentally equipped just to be by himself
and I think the character development is
there to go with that idea however thank
things might have altered though as in
his final goodbye to his wife and son he
touches them both showing things might
have changed now as with the first two
entries there's lots of callbacks to
other Black Mirror episodes Aaron Paul
actually gave a vocal Cameo on the space
themed USS Callister without potentially
being used due to him being a famous
astronaut might not be that celebrated
because he's probably known as a
murderer but there is the connection
there Beyond just this as well that
episode itself also dealt with similar
themes as it centered around men that
wanted to control women and went into a
rage when they couldn't get what they
were after on top of that at the start
of the entry there's a theater listing
for space Fleet which Robert in USS
Callister based his mod off so I think
the connections are definitely apparent
and it was theorize that this was
actually the first black mirror episode
that was a direct sequel to another I
don't think you need to watch that to
understand this one at all but there are
some mental gymnastics that you can pull
off to pair them together now in David's
Home the painted symbol from my bare
peers and this shows up in blood for a
split second this shows up about roughly
the 20 minute 30 Mark and the people
here are obviously based on the Manson
family with they're being ties to murder
this scene is of course newly similar
the murder of Sharon Tate and her guess
which happened in 1969 out in California
I also think that due to their motives
that this was ripping slightly on the
cold from the movie contact natso
Interstellar travel being listed as an
affront to God unless they attempted to
stop the experiments through using
brutal means now I'd definitely be
remiss if I also didn't talk about the
clear nods to 2001 A Space Odyssey bath
bombs feature characters traveling on
long distances that are separated from
their home and they miss birthdays have
to speak to their families who month old
voice recordings and are completely
detached from each other we have the
shapes having circular insights and one
of the characters is called David Cliff
is locked outside the airlock much like
how David was in that film but he's let
back in because Dave compare being alone
at least that's how I took it anyway I
know he was obviously off killing
Cliff's family but he could have easily
just have left cliff in space impo
pushing the chair at the end shows that
he needs someone and the mission itself
of course needs two people to man it he
welcomes him to be by his side and this
is even though he's done something that
will destroy any possible friendship
that the pair could have it's also
possible that they might even use
Cliff's replica back on Earth and this
could be a way that they keep journeying
back to the planet this offering appears
like a partnership with David
potentially wanting them to have this
thing that they can both use probably
wanted for murder but yeah we never see
Cliffs replica destroyed so I'm guessing
that it still works now we also have the
buck the Moon is a Harsh Mistress which
talks about people that live on the moon
battling for independence from Earth
cliff and David both still have
attachments to Earth but severing this
at the end means that they're now
independent from the planet in the book
those on the moon don't have the
equality that the people of Earth do and
they're very much fighting to have equal
rights equality could be something
that's seen in this episode too as David
leaves cliff in the same position as him
by killing all his family he pushes the
chair out almost as if he's an equal and
though that might be a rich it's there
if you want to see it now lastly is the
word mistress in the book which may be
playing on Lana though she doesn't
really come across that way either way
that ends the episode though and yeah
like I said I think it could have been
cut down but it has an ending that will
definitely stick with me for years and
years and years thing anyway might be
dead next week but you know what I mean
really well acted though and you can see
the character development here in full
effect and after watching this I hope
Josh hartner gets cast as Bruce Wayne
because the man looks like her I'd
imagine him too I know I know he nearly
got the role with Nolan but well look
I'm going off track anyway I will be
back with more breakdowns in the show
very shortly so make sure you stay
locked by hitting subscribe I am
actually thinking of combining episodes
four and five into one video just
because of how few connections there are
on four and it's ending also not being
massively complicated except for that
big twist let me know below if you're
cool with me just doing one video for
those two and if you want to see our
team's thoughts on the season then head
over to the streamer.com for Full Black
Mirror season 6 reviews you want to say
for the channel for as little as 99
cents a month then please click the join
button below and as a thank you you'll
get early access to videos every week we
also have our merch store over at
xerodation.com which sells lots of nerdy
inspired t-shirts hats and more you just
launched a secret Invasion slash Pulp
Fiction inspired t-shirt so if you want
to head over there and help us out then
the links in the description now if you
want some else to watch we've got a
Black Mirror breakdown on screen right
now so definitely head over there right
after this now the way huge thank you
for clicking through the video I've been
Paul and I'll see you next time you take
care peace
foreign